[موسيقى]
هذه العربه تم اختيارها عام 2018 لتكون
اليه الهجوم
لتحل محل عربه
الامريكيه اخراجها من الخدمه خلال السنوات
مباشر
بدا انتاج مركبه اي سي في عام 2020 بناء
على عقد لتصنيع الست وثلاثين اليه مع
امكانيه زياده العدد الى 80 الا هذه
الاليات تعرضت لحادثه في المنطقه الساحليه
العميقه خلال عمليه التدريب على الانزال
في شهر اكتوبر الماضي
لحين انتهاء التحقيقات
قياده مارينز يبدو انها مصره على المضيق
قدما في تزويد قواتها بجيل الجديد من عربه
القتال البرمائيه اي سي في على امل حل اي
مشكلات تقنيه عالقه خلال الفتره القادمه
حيث قررت البحريه الامريكيه التعاقد مع
شركه
البريطانيه على شراء 30 اليا برمائيه
جديده في عقد بلغت قيمته 154 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]